اذا ثمانيه مليارات نسمه هو عدد السكان
الذي سيصل اليه العالم في منتصف نوفمبر
الجاري وفقا للامم المتحده ما يعني ان
الارض رحبت بمليار انسان اضافي في نحو احد
عشر عاما واليكم مزيدا من الارقام واحد
وثمانون مليون انسان هو متوسط معدل
الزياده في عدد سكان الارض كل عام وثلاثه
بالمئه هي نسبه الزياده السنويه لسكان
العالم الذين يبلغون اعمارهم 60 عاما في
اكثر 8 بلدان ستكون مسؤوله عن اكثر من نصف
الزياده المتوقعه في عدد سكان العالم حتى
عام 2050 مصر والكونغو اثيوبيا ونيجيريا
وتنزانيا في افريقيا ومن اسيا الهند
وباكستان والفلبين
77.2 عاما هو متوسط العمر المتوقع للانسان
في عام 2050 تسعه مليارات شخص فاصل سبعه
هو
والسكان المتوقع عام 2050 رغم ذلك ستشهد
واحد وستون دوله بل احدى وستون دوله
تراجعا في عدد سكانها في نفس العامه
واخيرا 9
ملايين شخص هو العدد المتوقع لسكان العالم
الذين يبلغ اعمارهم 80 عاما واكثر عام